la descente aux enfers continue et on
peut dire parce que s'ils à la fiche de
plein de filles marie il paraît qu'il
est en plus dans le landais lous on
avait d'ailleurs formidable nous ce
qu'on sort aujourd'hui dans closer c'est
que le spectacle qu'il a écrit qu'il
devait tourner et qu'il est rodé en
province qui s'appelle pour de vrai on
savait que les dates avaient été annulés
à minima reporter et gilbert coullier
son producteur un grand producteur un
producteur tout le monde connaît
beaucoup connaissent lui réclamerait lui
réclame un gros gros millions d'euros de
manque à gagner de manque à gagner c à 8
c faire lui qui doit se retourner il ya
pas d assurance là dessus
nous sur ce qu'on sait c'est qu'il ya
des assurances qui ont été prises comme
pour tous les spectacles question après
une assurance qui couvrirait une mise en
examen pour viol a priori non donc c'est
pour ça que c'est plus compliqué c'est
pour ça que gilbert coullier lui
réclamerait cette somme là c'est pas une
brouille c'est pas une brouille d'hommes
ya pas de problème entre les deux c'est
juste une histoire de souche précise
quand même que j'ai eus l'avocate de
monsieur habitants d'accord m t'oublie
au téléphone qui elle dément puisqu'ils
dément le fait que gilbert coullier lui
réclamerait d'argent nous on n'écrit pas
les choses par hasard donc d'accord elle
est monté de sept mètres au toubib
où l'on
fait c'est des jeux d'assurance
effectivement alors évidemment les
producteurs ou les tourneurs ils
prennent des assurances multirisques
mais il ya une assurance spécifique qui
s'appelle la garantie homme clé et c'est
une garantie qui secteur tous
égards séance spécifique comme clé qui
fait que quand l'artiste ne se présente
pas par exemple les rockeurs anglais qui
sont pas en état de faire un concert ou
quand vous avez un problème que vous
êtes savalli couric ces extraits zon et
bien dans ces cas là il ya une assurance
mais selon nos infos ces assurances
hommes clés qui sont des clauses
spécifiques qui coûte pas très cher qui
sont pas toujours proposées elles
n'auraient pas été prises dans tous les
cas voilà et dans ces cas là vous n'êtes
plus du tout assuré ça peut coûter très
cher parce que le producteur il a
réservé la salle et à la billetterie qui
est engagée il ya un présumé innocent il
a fait cet arrêt oui mais on sait on n'a
rien à voir avec la sphère judiciaire
imaginons que demain il soit innocenté
comment il va faire ces informations
laissées par les assurances gilbert
coullier va faire quoi bien sûr mais là
les dates des spectacles ont déjà été
annulées vous pouvez pas les remettre si
et ça glisse même s'il est innocenté
maintenant il pourra plus refaire son
spectacle avant un an ou deux elle a
depuis tout à l'heure benhaim elle fait
est-ce que vous avez déjà essayé chez
vous quand vous êtes avec la
télécommande et boules sont les tiennes
mais très vite voir passer sous peine
après que tu dis que tu alors les
combats reversés pour du bt le propos de
gilles c'est effectivement si vous allez
sur les dates de la tournée vous riez
qu'elles sont toutes à nous les annuler
et comportementaux etc et que et que
l'on peut demander le remboursement des
frais engagés donc à un moment il va
falloir aussi bas c'est cette
billetterie la ccpo c'est pour ça que
gilbert coullier se retourne numéro
contrarier habitants je crois pas trop
mais quelque chose doit demander l'arrêt
habitants que quand même présumé
innocent d'avancé afin de rembourser
donc un million d'euros d'avancé cette
somme c'est s'il est innocent on va lui
rembourser jeudi c'est l'assurance qui
narre anticipation commence à dire ouh
là ça va coûter très cher j'ai compris
ils vont comprennent des garanties
noualhat sais quoi qui veulent avancer
alors pour elle j'ai appelé le
producteur il ya une heure qui dément
totalement le fait qu'on lui demande
c'est ce qu'annonce évidemment mais je
crois qu'il compte vous attaquez même
pour autre que vous avez écrit c'est
vous dire à quel point ils sont en
colère alors c'est le message que j'ai
eues en colère parce que c'est
absolument casser totalement ça c'est
apparemment totalement faux et c'est
vrai que c'est très bon pour l'instant
il est présumé innocent mais ce que vit
arrêt habitants quelles que soient ses 5
étoiles en effet c'est terrible parce
que effectivement entre les films
annuler les téléfilms annuler la tournée
annulée la promo qui peut pas faire très
bien moi je les mets dans le louche et
indépendamment de ce qui peut y avoir
comme fait il est formidable je crois
qu'il est formidable envie most hid dans
l'autre et c'est vrai que c est terrible
parce que si jamais il est innocenté un
juste blanchi
oui oui et ben quoi qu'il arrive je
pense que sa carrière pour l'instant
elle est totalement brisée
aujourd'hui c'est vrai qu'on n'en
parlait parfois plus personne dont le
métier
il lui propose des choses déjà il est
nous qui nous surprend c'est qu'il est
quand même assez peu défendu
publiquement par des acteurs des bernard
l'a fait ici bernard inc y est c'est
très bien on
sait ce qui s'est passé après c'est vrai
que claude lelouch a pris sa défense
dans une interview très récemment parce
qu'ils tournent arrêt habitants de
tourner dans un film réalisé par lelouch
c'est l'un des rares à l'avoir fait pour
ça que ça que j'en parle ça sort et puis
faut aussi quand même préciser que
l'équipe de qu'est ce qu'on a fait au
bon dieu le troisième volet est quand
même particulièrement muette depuis le
début de toute cette histoire là il ya
la promo qu'a commencé les dates les
projections en province ont commencé
compliqué pour moi je me suis un petit
peu renseigné sur le discours les
éléments de langage que les acteurs
doivent tenir auprès du public comme
auprès des journalistes c'est ary
abittan est en vacances c'est pour ça
qu'il est pas avec je sais pas vous mais
moi en général je pars en vacances quand
j'aurai rendez vous professionnel aussi
important une échéance aussi importante
donc voilà disons que c'est un petit peu
compliqué de démêler le vrai du faux que
les enjeux sont énormes immense et c'est
aussi pour ça que producteur l'horizon
cette information il est finalement dû
reculer a surtout
c'est pour raison de copies de logiciels
sont bien césar ce qu'ils ont bien fait
oui je suis répond non moi je trouve art
et à lenquête qui hélas est coupable ou
pas coupable pour l'instant il n'est pas
coupable à ces camps parfois je vous dis
ici on a on a des débats ensuite il
échangerait voilà c'est ça enflammé
chercher le morne à des délires enflammé
quand je vous dis c'est quand même des
métiers c'est spécial comme métier c'est
assez spécial aussi comme métier il n'y
a pas d'autre travail ou tout comme ça
tu est accusé et tonton tu bloques ton
travail moi si demain on m'accuse de
quelque chose que j'ai fait que la
justice j'irai travailler j'ai
reconduire mon camion étant que messi
velez sinon qu'il est moi mais bon pas
enseigner sera travail les juges et
j'aurai mon salaire donc sur la juger ça
ne rentre en aucun lieu à raison ma vie
privée là il aura dominé comme celle à
l'achat non je vous sais c'est un match
comme ça c'est sûr mais je te disent
merci
malgré s'ils étaient accusés mis en
examen pour viol
mon patron me dire est ce que tu as en
liberté oui est ce que tu peux circuler
ce moment oui alors t'es pas au chômage
ce n'est pas viré de match pour être
demain non c'est comme ça dans le
travail la raison mais bon ton camion tu
vas devrait etc et la secrétaire et
vient au bureau et elle vient faire ses
fiches de paie normalement il ya dans
vos métiers où il arrive des trucs comme
ça qu on dézingue un lac vous rendez
compte l'hypocrisie qu'est ce qu'on a
fait au bon dieu ils n'ont même pas
invité c'est dans la projection du film
il s'en lave les mains comme s'il avait
comme s'il était coupable ben à 100%
c'est peut-être mal abordé au 100% on ne
sait pas si c'est mieux pour lui on ne
sait pas là ça vole enquête volant
cabillaud volet c'est l'entraîneur c'est
qu'on voit vraiment l'hypocrisie du
milieu revoilà de visages ça qu'en privé
en off les gens disent t'inquiète pas et
sont très sympas et là pour toi en
revanche quand il s'agit d'avoir un peu
de courage et de prendre la défense
publiquement d'une personnalité qui
accusait là y'a plus personne et je
trouve qu'un vrai des cadres eux moi je
veux des moyens autre truc moi aussi
c'est vrai c'est comment il ya plein de
gens qui me met félicie well to et et je
vais sur leur compte twitter instinct et
défont sinon y voilà c'est vrai c'est
incroyable il ya un vrai décalage ont
toujours voulu venir se voit tout il ya
un vrai décalage
entre la violence de ce concours what we
do not ready recensement mais je gagne
des gens qui vont félicité qui part
derrière surtout laissez vous aller non
parce que la semaine
de faire ça deux qui voit la
[Musique]
personne qu'on ne verra plus on saurait
qui sait
dans le cadre du tribunal médiatique
c'est vrai qu'il est de bon ton
d'accuser publiquement ces gens-là
l'inra insulté sociaux etc je pense car
habitant quand les gens le croise dans
la rue je pense qu'il disait rien du
tout qui sont sympas avec lui et même
des gens qui prennent des photos et
mayala y en a qui le font si par respect
pour la balle à la victime holding fixe
et sert absolument oui c'est normal une
mise en examen bien sûr et moi raison de
présomption d'innocence mais une mise en
examen repose quand même sur des indices
qui sont jugés graves et sérieuses et
pas n'importe quoi et d'autre part c'est
vrai que si le film le bon dieu a été
retardé c'est officiellement pour le coc
vide mais en fait ils avaient quand même
peur des répercussions de la sortie du
film et d'une baisse d'audience d'une
baisse du public sur ce que la crainte
c'est ça c'est que le public se disent
on boycotte voilà